remember the conversation we had before
the cameras were on what do you mean
what conversation about the situation
you told me about I don't remember we
were just talking in general no but do
you remember about the situation you
told me about that I was giving you
advice on it was a general situation I
can't remember exactly where the red
fault what does that have to do with
this part because you just told everyone
here something that from that situation
I was that what were you talking about
because I wasn't talking about me and
myself in that situation you you were I
don't know you because maybe you don't
want to you don't want people to know
what you're talking about honestly I was
talking about situation with my friend
just in general but I don't know I just
met you do I know you look don't be rude
to me yeah because I'm not trying to be
very rude to be honest I'm just trying
to say some sort of no I haven't I
haven't hold on I've not said anything
about anything yeah I'm just saying do
you remember the conversation that we
had I remember some of the conversations
we had yeah most of them